welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today you
can find me on youtube at youtube.com
slash the Ring of Fire or follow me on
twitter at Ferren balanced you know one
of the things I love about some of these
Trump supporters out there is that they
are just so rabid in their defense of
the president that they don't care if
they make sense in fact some of them
don't even care if their defense of the
President and their desperation to take
down Democrats ends up causing them to
break the law and in case you're not
familiar with what I'm talking about I
am of course referring to Jacob Wall
everybody's favorite Pro Donald Trump
Twitter troll or at least he was until
he got booted off of Twitter for
creating a bunch of fake accounts and
it's actually those fake accounts that
cost him his Twitter feed that also
could land him in legal jeopardy here's
what's happened Jacob Wall recently took
a trip to Minnesota along with the
right-wing provocateurs Ollie Alexander
and Laura Loomer their goal was to make
this documentary film where they were
going to expose how representative Ilan
Omar married her own brother so that he
could become a US citizen that was the
goal of this documentary and along the
way Jacob wall as part of the film that
is now released goes to the police
office not because of what
representative Omar allegedly did but
because he received a death threat on
Twitter and I've seen the screenshots of
it it's a pretty disgusting message that
he has received from a man by the name
of Drake Holmes the only problem is when
he reported this death threat to the
police which he did in the documentary
and they showed the screenshot of these
messages and that dude's faces right
there he didn't know that in between the
time of filming this and airing it to
the public that he would get busted
for all of the fake accounts he created
so how did Jacob walls fake Twitter
accounts tie into Drake homes well the
simple fact that Drake homes was a
pseudonym or shouldn't even say suiting
him it was a fake account created by
Jacob wall
Jacob wall by all available evidence
created a fake account on Twitter just
to send himself a death threat so that
he could make it look like liberals were
after him his life was in danger
he didn't know what he was going to do
so he files a police report says please
look into this find this Drake Holmes
guy who somehow accidentally misspelled
his own name and his Twitter handle by
the way Jacob wall is a serial liar okay
we know that the story came out last
week or a week before whenever it was
that the woman he alleged had been
sexually assaulted by robert muller the
special prosecutor came out and said
yeah it never happened they told me to
do this
they actually tricked me into doing this
and that's why i ran away i had to
physically get away from him which is
what happened in the airport right
before if you all remember his little
press conference that he did it fell
apart his allegations against robert
muller fell apart just like his claims
of being threatened have fallen apart
the only difference is what he's done in
this case assuming he did do it
it's 100% illegal it's exactly what
Jessi Smollett allegedly did and has now
been arrested for and appeared in court
again today to have to answer for the
same thing has to happen to Jacob wall
at this point and to be honest I think
an investigation needs to be launched to
find out what Ali Alexander and Laura
Loomer knew as well because they were in
cahoots with Jacob wall and I find it
highly unlikely that these two
provocateurs did not know that their
little compatriot sitting next to them
in their little trip to Minnesota hadn't
created fake accounts hadn't sent
himself death threats and then helped
him film it and report it to the police
now this is bigger than just one Twitter
idiot
I think those other two were involved
and I think in order to find out whether
or not they were we need to have a
proper investigation of this and Olli
Alexander claims oh I'm gonna
investigate this oh I hope I wasn't
taken for a fool
I've been up against Olli in a debate
and let me tell you it's not that hard
to debunk everything the guy says I did
it live on the air I actually had to
pull up info on my phone cuz he refused
to believe that I was right and I had to
show it to him said no you are wrong and
you were lying be honest for once I
don't think he's being honest about this
I don't think Jacob wall is being honest
and what Jacob wall has done here with
filing this fake police report is 100%
criminal let's also not overlook the
fact that the guy is being investigated
by federal authorities for his fake
accusation against Robert Muller Jacob
wall needs help and I'm not saying that
to be mean I'm saying that if you go
through what he was saying on Twitter
like his weird crazy obsessive responses
to Donald Trump I truly believe that
this kid needs some help there's
something wrong you know I don't know
what it is I don't know what the answer
is but this kid needs to be in therapy
because he needs to get to the root of
what is happening to him and find the
answers he is so desperate to defend the
president and try to take down the left
that he's willing to break the law to do
it
a normal person doesn't think in that
manner but Jacob wall does hopefully
hopefully Jacob wall does get taken in
to custody because I believe he needs to
be in custody not just for these crimes
he may have committed but because this
kid is seriously a little bit not right
and he needs some therapy so they can
help him and make him better
there's still hope there's still a
chance but he's got to get to the root
of his problems instead of trying to
take down everyone even if it's illegal
in order to defend the president